la question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre le baccalauréat
porte d'entrée du supérieur avec la
charge symbolique qu'il revêt les émois
qu'il suscite pour des jeunes qui
passent là leur premier véritable examen
est au cœur de l'actualité de fait les
épreuves de spécialité du baccalauréat
tel que prévu par la dernière réforme
ont commencé hier
elle compte pour près d'un tiers de la
note finale et pour la première fois se
déroule enfin selon le calendrier prévu
bousculé par la covid ces deux dernières
années
le contexte social lié à la réforme des
retraites inquiète dans la mesure où des
blocages d'établissements ou des grèves
de surveillance peuvent venir perturber
les épreuves on imagine sans difficulté
l'angoisse des lycéens qui préparent ces
épreuves et la position délicate des
professeurs forcément tous très attachés
la réussite de leurs élèves quel que
soit leur choix je voudrais d'ailleurs
vous dire combien les assurés de notre
soutien est toujours nécessaire et plus
que jamais indispensable la profession
fait face à l'immenses difficultés dans
sa tâche quotidienne dans une société en
voie d'archipalisation et où l'autorité
est trop souvent remise en question
votre ministère a indiqué que des
surveillants supplémentaires ont été
convoquées et il ne semblait pas exclu
qu'on puisse recourir au préfet en cas
de difficultés pour accéder au centre
d'examen pouvez-vous nous faire un point
de situation combien d'élèves n'ont pas
pu passer leurs épreuves quelle
possibilité pour eux de le faire quelle
vigilance aussi pour la phase de
correction merci de votre éclairage